[Music]
2022 scream pays tribute to scream by
bringing back characters from scream to
face the killer from scream all over
again screaming yet this is the ending
of the fifth scream movie scream
explained i've seen this movie before
not this movie sydney the film kicks off
with a very typical setup tara carpenter
is home alone when a stranger starts
calling her landline phone shocker the
new ghost face has found his first
victim when tara's estranged sister sam
gets a call from wes hicks about the
attack on tara jihao puts it to her
hometown with her helpful boyfriend
richie in tow when she arrives she's
quickly interrogated by tara's fiercely
protected best friend amber to be fair
amber's suspicions make sense sam
conveniently comes home the day after
tara is attacked it seems too good to be
true resident film nerds chad and mindy
are quick to point out ghost faces
involved and anyone could be behind the
mask even the main character
we're all suspects we find out that sam
left woodsboro because she uncovered a
dark family secret she's the secret
daughter of billy loomis and suffers
from hallucinatory visions of billy
himself what's the matter sydney you
look like you've seen a ghost
what do you do when a new ghost face
starts hunting your family and friends
well you get help from someone with
expertise of course enter dewey riley
the washed-up former sheriff lives alone
in his trailer separated from gayle
weathers he helps the new class of
victims establish that the killer is
trying to make his own requel a reboot
sequel which is why the new killer is
going after anyone connected to the
previous killing sprees ghostface even
slaughter screamed four alum judy hicks
and her son wes in a stunningly tense
sequence inside the hicks house
look it just wouldn't be a legacy sequel
if one of the original characters didn't
die in a sacrificial blaze of glory the
film was all about passing the torch so
obviously a fan favorite character has
to meet their end at some point gail
weathers is the second legacy character
to show up in the film arriving in
woodsboro to cover the news for her
successful morning show although she
divorced dewey after scream 4 they
reunite at the hicks house which gives
them the opportunity to resolve the
issues that drove them apart oh no
character development you can see where
this is going ghostface obviously
doesn't stop with the hicks family
making their way to the hospital where
tara is recovering so they can finish
the job they started in the film's
opening thankfully dewey shows up
shooting ghostface in the chest several
times so sam can get tara to safety but
as soon as he steps into the hallway
he's practically signed his own death
sentence the killer butchers dewey with
two knives ripping his abdomen and back
to shreds until he bleeds out on the
floor rest in peace do we thankfully
gail has sydney to lean on for support
which is surprising since they've always
had an uneasy relationship over the
years while all this is happening the
teenagers are holding a remembrance
party for wes and stu mocker's old house
the place where the original finale
happened it wouldn't be scream without a
party now wouldn't but then most of the
partygoers leave after realizing that
just by the act of being there they're
practically begging to be killed
sounds about right chad is attacked by
ghostface while various members of the
group like liv tara and richie go
missing but this is scream we're talking
about so there are always going to be
plenty of red herrings for the audience
to overanalyze thankfully fans don't
have to wait long for resolution because
in a moment of extreme paranoia in the
group amber whips out a gun and executes
live at point-blank range welcome to act
3 indeed but who's her accomplice well
the writers clearly subvert a typical
trope in the franchise because surely it
can't be the main character's boyfriend
again can it actually yes it can as
richie outs himself to sam sydney and
gail as amber's accomplice in typical
scream fashion the two killers wax
lyrical about their motives and it's
just about as meta as you'd expect turns
out amber and richie are both
disgruntled fans of the stab franchise
you know the movie series within a movie
that's based on the events of the
original movie they bonded online over
their shared hate for the most recent
film stab 8 before coming up with the
idea for their own movie amber and
richie go on their killing spree so the
stab franchise has fresh source material
to work with going forward by creating
their own ghost phase the duo hopes to
essentially shape the narrative of the
next film believing that their ideas for
a sequel are better than anything the
studio will come up with in richie's own
words someone has to save the franchise
that was so
stupid pure horse the death of horror
right here in front of us it's a clever
maneuver from the writers who are
clearly taking pot shots at specific
fandoms in the real world who go on mass
hate campaigns when specific movies and
sequels aren't to their liking
although amber and richie feel they've
created a victim-proof plan to frame sam
as the new killer in their stab requel
they don't account for the fact that she
has an inner darkness that is
personified by the billy loomis
hallucinations it's a clever way of
turning the deadly loomis legacy into
something positive as sam tells richie
he shouldn't mess with the daughter of a
serial killer before stabbing him over
and over
i'll be right back
he's dead
amber doesn't get away either as sydney
and gail tag team the teenage killer in
the kitchen knocking her back so she
face plants on the lit stovetop setting
her on fire
it's a horrifying fate for the
disillusioned student but it's also some
sweet revenge for gail since this is
scream we're all expecting the killers
to get back up for one final scare but
we get yet another subversion here as
sam unloads several shots into richie's
bloody body before that happens out of
the new cast there's a healthy batch of
survivors with tara sam chad and mindy
all making it out alive after everything
sydney and gail have been through over
the years they both deserve a happy
ending although gail makes a point of
saying she's not going to write about
the killers no this time she's going to
write about dewey she's arrived at a
point where she doesn't need to
memorialize the evil in the world gail's
ready to honor those who always try to
do good now that's what we call
character development
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one